so I don't know any better way to put
this so let me just say it directly we
are stopping uploads on think media
after talking to my family after talking
to the team after a lot of processing
and a lot of thought this is the
conclusion that we've come to and so
officially we are stopping uploads on
think media for the next 10 days okay
relax I know that this kind of seemed a
little clickbaity but actually this is a
super important topic because in this
episode of the think media podcast I'm
going to be talking about four reasons
why rest and Recovery is critical to
your success as a content creator and
stick with me because I actually believe
that this episode could save your life
no exaggeration let's get into it all
right here's what's happening so we're
actually shutting down think media for
an entire week and when you add the
weekends that actually ends up being 10
days where we're not going to do any
uploads on YouTube or across social
media and it's actually not that we
couldn't do uploads because we do batch
produce content we do get ahead but
there's a few reasons why we've decided
to do this and so in this episode I want
to share four of those with you mainly
because I think there's a lot we can
learn about longevity about health and I
think that there's going to be nuggets
for you that you can apply in your own
YouTube business and as a content
creator number one is rest and Recovery
are essential for Peak Performance and
so in sports nobody questions the value
of exercise training for Optimal
Performance and Improvement in content
creation nobody questions putting in the
work putting in the hustle you gotta
grind you gotta get the work done I'm
not talking about hustle culture but I'm
talking about hard work like it's one of
the requirements however rest in
recovery back to sports is equally
essential in any exercise program
because it gives the body time to repair
rebuild and strengthen itself between
workouts the notable difference between
Elite athletes and average athletes is
not the quality of their training it's
the quality of their recovery and their
rest and so we've been trying to learn
that lesson here at think media and I
was actually reading a quote from a book
The Athlete's guide to recovery and it
says a decline in performance should
lead to a search for its cause and a
focus on the quality of your recovery if
for some reason you start to go down in
performance you start to decline you
start to have things suffer in your
business or your channel it could be an
indication that it's time to rest
recover so you can heal and get back to
your A game this is actually a faith
move for us because here I think media
things are actually going really well
things are growing we have a lot of
momentum but we also want to stay at
Peak Performance and just because it
feels like we're in this groove we don't
want to push ourselves too hard and miss
out on the opportunity for rest and
recovery and so the action we decided to
take was to give our entire team an
entire paid week off in addition to
their normal two weeks of vacation in
addition to the fact we take federal
holidays off you add up different six
days sick days and things like that this
year our team at think media is actually
going to have a little over six weeks of
time off and just as a side note this
has been kind of one of our cultural
goals it hasn't been this way Forever
This is the first year we're doing the
Sabbath week thing and we're going to
see how it goes but we're really excited
about it because we always want to
continue to steer our company culture
towards our highest values and this is a
big move in that direction rest and
Recovery are an essential piece of Peak
Performance and we want to continue Peak
Performance over the Long Haul here at
think media number two YouTube is a
marathon and not a Sprint our company
theme this year is built to to last
a lot of people's business models though
is built for Burnout I mean it's kind of
true if you are running an unsustainable
Pace the problem with that
is that it's unsustainable and
ultimately we should be asking the
question is what I'm doing right now
something that I can keep up can I
actually maintain this pace can I keep
this thing going you know I've been
impacted by the book The Infinite game
by Simon sinek
which encourages leaders to shift from
short-term thinking to infinite thinking
the objective is not to win the game The
Objective is to keep playing and in the
book they talk about finite games and
infinite games a game of chess you're
gonna play it until you defeat the
opponent a game of sports you're going
to play the game and tell you to defeat
the opponent one of the things and
points he makes though is that this is
actually a horrible way to run a
business I actually think this is a
horrible way to run a YouTube channel
because if you're just playing short
term like I want to defeat all opponents
and I just want to win well what does
winning even mean is winning a point in
time or is winning actually the ability
to stay in the game because you can win
one Championship but what happens if 10
years later 20 years later 30 years
later you never quote unquote win again
the better objective is to play an
infinite game and so at think media as
I've matured and grown as a leader I'm
asking myself really how can we just
stay in business like how can we keep
paying our team keep serving our
customers keep serving our listeners
keep serving our viewers and if we have
spurts of growth great if we even
Plateau a little bit great so long
though is we can just keep playing the
game because we love doing this we love
creating content we love marketing we
love building the business we love
serving people we love events we love
writing books we love creating content
all the different things that we get to
do we want to stay and play an infinite
game and if you burn out
you can't keep playing
if you destroy your brand it's difficult
or impossible to rebuild your brand and
so it's game over and so we don't want
to hear game over we just want to stay
in the infinite game YouTube is a
marathon and not a Sprint we don't want
to be built to burn out we want to be
built to last and so these are some of
the questions we've been asking how can
we stay in the game not just over a year
but over decades rest is going to be a
big piece of that
how can we create here at think media a
healthy Pace rest is going to be a big
piece of that and I love this quote from
Steve Jobs this has influenced me a lot
as a business owner over the years I
think this would be very encouraging to
you as a content creator that's trying
to break through the noise maybe you're
trying to beat the competition not that
it's a finite game but you're you're
trying to get ahead you're feeling like
the underdog in business you feel like
maybe it's hard to get your market share
it's hard to break through listen to
what Steve Jobs said he said business is
a game of attrition most people just
fall off if you just stand there long
enough then you actually will still be
standing when everybody else is gone
the interesting thing is if you have a
long-term perspective if you're playing
an infinite and not a finite game then
you're not just trying to go viral this
week you're not just trying to like make
this thing work and making short-term
moves with short-term thinking in the
next 365 days the question really
becomes I don't care if I'm
fifth place 15 I don't care if I'm not
even in the top 100 I don't care if I'm
just building up my YouTube channel in
obscurity and I'm unknown for one two
three four five years if I can just work
my way into a sustainable healthy
Creator business online business and
then just maintain that for the rest of
my life enjoying what I do with a
sustainable pace
if I just keep standing and I'm able to
persevere
most other people are going to disappear
that's what Steve had noticed as a
business Legend was that again if you're
just still standing so why are we
resting well we want to play the
infinite game and we don't want to just
have a Sprint of success for a couple of
years and then disappear we want to play
this for the Long Haul so that's why
we're choosing to do a Sabbath week here
at think media number three Creator
economy businesses have unique
advantages and benefits
so another reason why we want to do this
is like what's the purpose of money
anyways
what's the purpose of all the hard work
we've put in
and at some point I get it you might
also be saying which seems good for you
Sean like I wish I could take a week off
you know friend honestly I've been doing
this for seven years 10 years before
that it took a long time to get to this
point I've had to put a lot of work in
and a lot of patience and a lot of
perseverance and you never want to judge
your season by somebody else's season it
took a long time to get here to have
even this freedom and this opportunity
but it was also once we got some
momentum and got some money and had some
savings and had some momentum and team
and some automation the question becomes
do you just keep pushing what's the
point like do you push yourself to burn
out or push yourself too hard or just
keep pushing when there is money in the
bank account you start asking okay if
there's money in the bank account
but there's not Health in my body and
I'm still chasing money
I got my priorities wrong if there's
money in the bank account but there's
not Health in my marriage but I'm still
chasing money I got my priority
priorities wrong now you need money for
the mission some people criticize
chasing money to their detriment and
it's really an act of foolishness
because money is a tool you got to
support your family you got to build
your business you gotta have some margin
you got to have an emergency fund but
like having all of these what's the
point of also the Creator economy with
the fact that YouTube's a search engine
you can rank videos digital advertising
you can still run ads and have the
leverage of having digital advertising
on meta and different platforms and you
know as we take the Sabbath week we're
giving our team off but there's still
like a contractor here or there that's
still working they're maybe not like our
core team we're also going to keep our
ads going because if you actually
completely shut your ads off it can kind
of mess up your ad account and different
things that can happen so we're not like
treating this in some kind of like a
hyper religious like weird way so if you
actually still see content from us it's
probably because of the power of these
digital platforms I mean it's not like
we're gonna unlist and private our
ranked videos
um and so that is the advantage of the
Creator economy and Creator businesses
ranked videos ranked products I mean
people discover my book and buy my book
just all the time like just because it's
it ranks on Amazon and I want to
encourage you one of the reasons
depending on the season you're in to
keep hustling to keep persevering to
keep putting in the work and to create
leverage to purposefully invest in
things like ranked videos in things like
a library of content that gets you views
24 7 into automated email sequences and
building funnels and into products that
you can create once and so many times is
so that you can create a business around
a lifestyle that is sustainable and that
you love and that can you know give you
Peak happiness and create health for you
and those around you and your team and
whoever else you have a vision of
creating an awesome culture for the
Creator economy is incredible and it
offers many benefits and so we want to
take advantage of those benefits and
practice what we preach again we work
really hard at think media and I hope
you know that that's also because we
deeply value your time and your
attention and the fact you'd even be a
part of this podcast and so we want to
serve yeah we want to give you the best
content possible but we also want to
model what health to the best of our
ability you know we're on a mission to
help one million purpose-driven people
create a full-time living doing what
they love will make it a difference with
YouTube in the world and to experience
that success without losing their soul
we sometimes don't say that last line
but it's very much a part of our company
ethos we want people to experience the
success and the Creator economy and
YouTube without losing their soul what
does that mean that one means that if
you climb the biggest mountain but you
sacrifice your family on the way we
think you did it wrong if you climb the
biggest mountain and you sacrifice your
health not just because something hits
you because that can just happen in life
but because you literally ground
yourself to the Bone and destroyed your
health because of overwork and
repetitive stress things that I've done
and mistakes I've done in the past and
I'm regaining my health because of the
sheer hustle in my 20s that's probably
one of the biggest things that I've
neglected in my 20s was I was working at
a computer for so long and not actually
doing strength training and other things
that gave me chronic pain in my hands
and my arms that thank God I'm actually
recovering from as I create more margin
invest in my health create a better pace
and so number three crater economy
businesses have unique advantages and
benefits and then number four
my checkbook and my calendar should
reflect my values and my priorities
does your checkbook and does your
calendar reflect your values and your
priorities now it's one thing to write
down a value it's one thing for me to
write down that I value family
it's a whole nother thing to have the
humility to allow a third party to audit
your checkbook in your calendar now
there's probably nobody that's going to
do that
but if somebody externally was to
inspect your planner inspect your Google
calendar if somebody externally was to
look at your credit card statement would
those things actually reflect your
stated values and your priorities
I know I'm guilty of saying yeah you
know one of my top priorities is health
and then you look at my calendar and
they say Well when did you invest in
your health on your calendar though well
one of my top priorities is my marriage
well the question is when I look at the
credit card when when where on your
credit card is signals and signs that
you've invested in your marriage and so
some of our values here at think media
one is family and this is true for so
many of our team members and and so
taking a week off again in addition to
federal holidays and weekends and
everything else like this is just a shut
the company down extra week we're going
to shut it down even more around the
holidays give a couple extra days in
addition to the federal holidays that
are off like for sure but this is like a
full in addition to everything else
amounting to a little over six weeks
total and our goal is to see how much we
can increase that you know even as a
side note I was talking to somebody who
works at a company with unlimited
vacation and I've heard that
that actually kind of backfires and
isn't as cool as it sounds because I
said that's super cool so how much
vacation you get to take and he goes
probably not even two weeks and it was
like because of the pressure and because
of like the responsibility of his job
and because of the company culture it's
like yeah you get unlimited vacation
but is that but do people use it do you
get fired if you use it you know
sometimes it actually kind of can create
confusion so I don't know what it's like
in your job but we are doing our best to
really build a company that's built to
last and so if we're going to Value
family that's what we're saying this
year is also like we want you to have
margin with your families uh to have
less stress not like hey you get time
off but you don't get paid like you also
get paid so that's the people that work
here and I've learned that no amount of
money or success can take the place of
time spent with family you know marriage
the more you invest in your marriage the
more valuable it becomes for us we're
excited because we're coming up with our
two and a half year old he'll be three
and our I will have a one-year-old and a
three-year-old about the time that we're
doing this I mean I take that back we
won't in about a month they'll be that
age so that's what they're coming up on
but for the first time
we will actually both be leaving because
we'll have the help and they're at a
solid enough age that Sony and I will be
able to go on like a proper we've done a
few little things but we're going to go
on like a proper three night at a spa on
the waterfront full deal and uh one of
the things we're gonna do during our
week is is go invest in our marriage
trying I'm doing my best to make my
checkbook and my calendar reflect my
values and my priorities of course
Health you know the biggest area I
neglected in my 20s and early 30s was
health I'm super grateful that I've been
on probably a couple years and really
the last six months of investing in my
health I'm doing 100 push-ups a day
challenge just finished that in July and
so that means I did 3100 push-ups in
July more because some days I snuck in a
little bit more I'm not trying to flex
literally here on the podcast but but
I'm just trying to actually say yeah my
calendar and my actions are reflecting
my priorities
and then faith
and you know as we land a plane we are
calling this a Sabbath week and we have
different backgrounds of beliefs that
our company it's not like everyone's a
Christian at the company uh but but a
lot of us really value our faith and you
know one of God's top ten one of the Ten
Commandments is literally about taking a
Sabbath taking a day of rest and what's
kind of crazy is that it's in the same
list as do not murder do not commit
adultery do not steal and a lot of us
would probably agree yeah like there's
some stuff you probably shouldn't do I
mean you know yeah you might say I'm a
good person too like I don't murder
anybody I don't you know I'm not
cheating uh I'm not stealing anything
what's so wild though is that in that
same list of the Ten Commandments is
like keep the Sabbath holy and you know
God's commands are actually for our
benefit they're not to remove our fun
they're for our benefits so it really
shows that I think in culture we have
lost the importance and power of this
idea of taking rest and uh in Exodus it
talks about like observe the sabbath day
keep it holy six days do your ordinary
work and on the seventh day make it a
day of rest dedicated to the Lord your
God and no one in your household should
do any work that includes you your sons
and daughters I'm gonna make my boys
still work just kidding they're too
young I'm kind of kidding uh that
includes you your sons and daughters
your male and your female servants now
we don't have any servants your
livestock your foreigners living among
you
um and of course this Old Testament
language but this is one of the faith
moves that we're doing we're trying to
say like we don't want to just as the
CEO and founder my wife and co-founder
of think media Sony and I we like we've
got a cool life we're trying to build a
company that is a sustainable pace and
especially in honoring this scripture we
wanted to uh give our company a week off
and and everybody kids livestock pets
like the whole deal you know and
ultimately have that rest and it says
that this is why the Lord blessed the
Sabbath day because for six days the
Lord made the Heaven and the Earth and
seeing everything in them but on the
seventh day he rested now
this is a common practice already for us
what is this talking about one day a
week and typically Sundays for us
because we're not in any kind of
ministry uh like actively in the sense
of we're able to actually go to church
kind of relax take a nap really focus on
our family so honoring the Sabbath is
already something Sony and I are doing
our best at but there was also versus in
the book that talk about
um and and customs of sometimes having
weeks off of Celebration or even having
a whole year off of letting the land
rest like there's a reason when they
want
Harvest fields to be most productive
there's they take
off planting for one year to let the
soil regain its energy and regrain its
gain its strength I wish that
illustration was better prepared but you
could look that up at another time so
even this principle that God wove into
the universe that man God's all about
work it's a blessing all about
productivity all about impact all about
be fruitful and multiply all about build
something all about let's go you know
I'll Advance the goal of the Gospel like
so that's all that's this is not a
contradiction to that
but if we want to be the most fruitful
and the most productive there's actually
something supernaturally powerful about
the Sabbath and so this is a a bold move
on our seventh year of our company to
even go above and beyond with a little
extra rest I also hope this becomes more
of our culture and you know later on
this isn't a fully religious thing that
might sound funny I know we have
different backgrounds and all kinds of
different people here that think media
whatever you believe I'm super grateful
you're here or whatever your background
is but I think there's principles to
learn here because for some people they
keep this at like they have like guilt
or shame or there's like a real
religious duty to keeping the Sabbath in
the New Testament and under the New
Covenant Jesus really said you know the
Sabbath is made for man man wasn't made
for the Sabbath like we're not here to
serve some religious Festival
God made the Sabbath to serve man to
actually be a part of our rhythms and
our cadences that we could ultimately
live our best life have the most
sustainable Pace have healthy families
healthy mental health healthy physical
health I'm trying to learn this I don't
want this to sound preachy at all I I'm
trying to actually Implement these
things seeing how truly powerful they
are especially as I mature and come up
on my 40th birthday this year and so
this is an act of faith for us it's an
act of worship it also reminds me that I
don't worship work I worship God and
it's also a time of reflection and
celebration of the goodness of God and
so a time to slow down a little bit look
back what have we accomplished
look at how far we've come God you've
been so good to us at think media and
our team and thank you for this
community and this think media podcast
family and all this different stuff
that's been built and so to have a
little time of with family naps I'm
gonna take a lot of naps uh rest and
some relaxation but also time to reflect
and celebrate the goodness of God and so
passing the question off to you a couple
things for application does your
checkbook and does your calendar reflect
your priorities
second question
how can you create better patterns and
routines even if you're in a sacrifice
season
and what resources when resources are
scarce and money is scarce could you
steal
schedule some time or be intentional
about some time about investing in rest
and Recovery if there's one lesson that
I look back
I would have preferred to have gone a
little bit slower or been a little bit
more intentional over the last decade
specifically about health and about rest
and Recovery
even if it meant I wasn't quite as far
as I was right now because as I'm
growing I'm like learning Life as a
marathon business is a marathon YouTube
is a marathon it's not a Sprint and I
think in sprinting
um the way even it's affected my body
and how it's broke down a little bit I'm
learning okay
Elite athletes that was that was not an
elite move amateur athletes push it too
hard Elite athletes don't just train
well and work hard
they have a quality of rest and Recovery
that's at another level and uh we hope
to continue to do that here at think
media so I appreciate you and didn't
mean to click bait you with the title
but I legitimately we're not uploading
for 10 days we're pretty much uploading
every day right now on both channels
because of YouTube shorts and because of
all that kind of stuff and so ultimately
um we'll see you soon it's not even that
long but it is a big a move of faith for
us those are the four reasons why we're
doing that and I can't wait to of course
connect with you soon on the next
episode of the think media podcast
coming back to you I believe on like
August 15th it drops again and then the
shorts and the videos start back up and
in the meantime keep crushing it keep
smashing it and check out some past
episodes of the think media podcast I
know that one of the things I will
definitely do during my week off is uh
invest in one of my values which is
learning and education there's books I
need to catch up on and there's things I
want to catch up on and some of those
might be a little more kind of just
personal development scripture or Bible
study and but some just kind of books
that I enjoy and that are refreshing
um and a lot of that has to do with
because I love what I do and so this is
a chance for you to perhaps check out
some past videos in our library
um write and review the podcast and also
if you are watching the YouTube version
of this I would love your feedback any
thoughts on um taking a Sabbath week any
thoughts on what it is we're doing I
love your feedback and I can't wait to
connect with you soon when we are back
after the break for the think media
podcast